il n'y a pas de lien nourrissent
despatie aucun mais on reste dans le
domaine scolaire
la fédération autonome de l'enseignement
aujourd'hui a dit vous savez vous on ne
négocie plus avec le gouvernement du
québec seules les forces et 34 mille
enseignants principalement dans le grand
montréal
oui alors elle quitte la fédération
autonome de l'enseignement quitte la
table sectorielle
cependant elle va continuer de négocier
l'aspect salarial mais ce qui est tout
le sectoriel en fait ce qui gravite
autour de l'école les ratio maître
élèves la charge de travail les services
d aide aux élèves en difficulté en fait
les conditions de travail des
enseignants
ça s'est terminé la fpe a interrompu ses
négociations avec le gouvernement
son président dit que le gouvernement
négocie les mains vides
il veut régler à coût nul alors dès
lundi il y aura conseil syndical tous
les syndicats membres de la fédération
vont étudier différents scénarios
je vous rappelle qu'il reste une journée
de grève dont la date doit être fixée il
y en a eu 2 mais il en reste une on
écoute sylvain mallette le président de
la ffr nous allons aussi évaluer
collectivement
de quelle façon nous pouvons obtenir un
déblocage à la table de négociation puis
on pense qu'en posant le juste qu'on
pose aujourd'hui c'est d'envoyer un
message clair mais un message qui est
fort aussi
nous n'accepterons pas une détérioration
de nos conditions de travail on est là
pour améliorer nos conditions de travail
alors martin coiteux le président du
conseil du trésor a réagi en rappelant
qu'il ya des offres de nouvelles
propositions à venir au sein du cac sans
être plus précis on écoute martin
coiteux bientôt ça sera bientôt c'est un
travail plus un travail qui est très
important à faire bien entendu
le plus que je peux dire à ce stade si
c'est qu'on n'a pas devant nous des mois
on nous dit semaine et à partir du
moment où on va déposer des offres qui
tiennent compte de tout le travail qui a
été fait que j'estime constructif
flahaut table de négociations une fois
qu'on va déposer des offres
actualisé ça va pouvoir accélérer la
cadence quant au ministre de l'éducation
il est à l'étranger mais le cabinet de
françois blais répète à l'intention d'un
fer que les solutions doivent être
trouvées aux tables de négociation et
qu'une éventuelle entente doit respecter
la capacité de payer des contribuables
on dit en éducation que la répétition
fixe la notion est bien patrice de part
et d'autre il ya beaucoup de gens qui
répète les mêmes choses ces jours ci
c'est normal sur négociations tant que
c'est pas fini c'est pas fini - merci
anne louise au revoir